konzentrieren wir uns auf olaf scholz 12
ja
da muss man zunächst einmal respekt
zollen die spd hat der begriff respekt
in die politische debatte in diesem jahr
in den mittelpunkt gerückt und wenn man
die spd situationen analysiert muss man
respektieren was dieser partei gelungen
ist ist ein politisches wunder sie waren
nämlich politisch weitgehend am ende sie
haben ich darf daran erinnern bei der
letzten landtagswahl vor drei monaten
8,4 prozent erreicht sie waren nicht der
erste nicht zweite und dritte sie haben
in den letzten jahren seit der
kanzlerschaft von gerhard schröder
300.000 mitglieder verloren und es ging
bei dieser wahl auch um die frage wer
ist eigentlich in der zukunft die
volkspartei der linken mitte sind es die
grünen die das bessere personal und das
interessantere wird interessanteren
auftritt haben oder es ist die alte
tante spd und wir alle haben die spd
abgeschrieben und sie haben es geschafft
wieder vorne zu sein das ist ein großer
politischer erfolg den muss man
respektieren jetzt ist die frage wird
der kanzlerkandidat der spd wirklich
kanzler und da glaube ich auf der
zielgeraden lauern 3 fallen und wie
könnten verhindern dass er ganze wird
die erste ist der ist nicht aus eigener
kraft in den umfragen vorne es gibt
keine positive wechselstimmung oder eine
begeisterung für olaf scholz wie damals
bei willy brandt oder auch eine
wechselstimmung wie nach dem ende der
ära kohl zum service wollen wir mal
wirklich das andere lager ran lassen
weil die spd regiert von den letzten 25
jahren 21 in diesem land das heißt es
ist amorph es ist zerbrechlich diese
zustimmung die ist in wahrheit nur da
weil die anderen so viele fehler machen
deswegen wirkt er relativ gut der zweite
grund ist die medien betrachten auf
einmal olaf scholz so kritisch wie sie
vor vier monaten vor baerbock betrachtet
haben und vor zwei monaten dann laschet
das führt dazu dass die new york times
immerhin die wichtigste zeitung der welt
sagt der mann seine langweiligste man
überhaupt es sei interessanter einen
topf kochendem wasser zu gucken als ihm
und solche analysen hat die kommen jetzt
hoch und da gucken die medienkritische
hin übrigens auch in die skandale comex
wirecard wir hatten heute eine razzia im
finanzministerium auf einmal kommen
diese themen hoch das heißt es wird für
ihn ein bisschen unangenehm und der
letzte punkt ist das thema rot rot grün
das ist auf der tagesordnung und dann er
und die spd das nicht beenden und das
nicht ausschließen wecken sie die
schlafenden die mobilisierten
frustrierten cdu bilder die eigentlich
nicht mehr cdu wählen und die wirken sie
gerade auf und deswegen ist meine these
respekt wurde vor dem comeback der spd
aber am ende wird das doch
siehst du alles wissen wir erst mal das
müssen erstmal also ich versuche mich in
einer gegenrede der vorsprung ist jetzt
so groß das wird wirklich schwer es zu
wenden zweiter der kandidat der es
schaffen kann oder müsste armin laschet
das maximal angeschlagen drittens die
skandal ließ die skandale die olaf
scholz
sozusagen in denen eine rolle spielt ich
will man eine kurze reihung versuchen
schauen wir doch mal auf das so können
wir mal schauen wir doch mal auf das was
olaf scholz wirklich beeinflussen konnte
man nimmt ja oft politiker in haftung
für etwas wo sich sozusagen mitmachen
konnten aber er war ja nur bürgermeister
von hamburg als die stadt abgebrannt ist
bei g20 untersatz schöne der oper hat
sich musik angehört comics und wirecard
klingt nicht nach einer wirklichen
erfolgsgeschichte sondern er nach
skandalen und man weiß nicht genau da
irgendwas vergessen die hamburger wissen
ja also wenn man als erster
bürgermeister drei mal den chef der
größten bank trifft dann ist es beim
ersten mal allein und beim zweiten mal
sind und leute dabei die hinterher
aufschreiben können was war da erinnerte
sich jetzt gar nicht mehr dran das ist
also sagen wir mal kein gutes keine gute
eigenschaft für einen künftigen kanzler
und die razzia heute die hat ja auch in
sich meint geht es um machenschaften
von von terrorfinanzierung bis
drogenhandel und so weiter und er regt
sich heute darüber auf und sagte er
hätte auch gereicht das schönste daran
er hat gesagt er regt sich darüber auf
weil man hätte ihm die fragen ja auch
schriftlich schicken können da hätte man
keine verschicken müssen das ist also
sozusagen sein rechtsverständnis ihm dem
titel und olaf kann man also die fragen
auf schrieb wie also ich glaube
dass auch das an ihm abprallt und dass
deshalb all das was auf dem zettel steht
das für und gegen ihn spricht am ende
für entspricht er kommt über die
ziellinie glauben ja gut richtig wie
gegen seinen eigenen verein wetten na ja
ja wir sind da der länger schon im
mediengeschäft und wir haben ja erlebt
wie volatil umfragen sein können ja und
gerade in den letzten ein zwei drei
jahre haben wir doch so häufig erlebt
dass sich um fragen der irrtum denn die
die umfragen sind ja keine prognose
sondern das ist eine momentaufnahme
was war was haben die leute in der
vergangenen woche gedacht ja
und dann ist eben noch ein
riesenunterschied ob sie von irgendwem
am telefon so angerufen werden um so
eine gewisse stimmung oder ob sie dann
tatsächlich hier in der wahlkabine
stehen oder die briefwahl machen und ein
coaching hat da sage ich ich zwischen
umfrage und realer entscheidung noch ein
schritt ja und gerade bei der cdu denke
ich dass sie eine recht stabile
wähler claire und denen auch eine ältere
klientel hat die wechsel nicht so leicht
also die sind nicht so
wechselfreudig wie die umfragen das
jetzt hier
zum ausdruck bringen was ich habe das
noch nie erlebt dass eine partei die mit
zehn prozentpunkten abstand führt
innerhalb von sechs wochen überholt wird
ja und eine andere 9 prozentpunkte
dazugewinnen weil wahlkampf schon mal
erlebt wo das passiert ist also ich noch
nicht so und deswegen sage ich das geht
vielleicht nicht ganz mit rechten dingen
zu und
wollten du hast ja auch erwähnt die wahl
in sachsen anhalt könnt ihr euch noch
erinnern da war doch zwei wochen vorher
die diskussion könnte vielleicht die die
afg stärker werden als die cdu also
irgendwie lagen die so fast gleichauf
bei 30 prozent so und und dann in den
letzten ein zwei wochen hat sich das
nach und nach verändert und es hat sich
vielleicht da bei vielen bürgern so ein
gewisses bedürfnis nach stabilität nach
kontinuität wird
verfestigt und die deutschen sind ja
auch ob es ein eher risikoscheu es folgt
ja und sie wurden im zweifel mit dem
beharrungsvermögen mit dem mit dem
bekannten und er gegen das unbekannte so
und die sachsen anhalt das sagen doch
die umfragen granatenmäßig daneben ja
also danach kann die cdu mit was weiß
ich 37 prozent und die fdp mit 1 und 20
also also 16 17 prozentpunkte
auseinander so und das ist der grund
warum ich glaube dass wir jetzt so einen
irgendwie öffentlich auch angefachten
trend haben die umfragen kommen und dann
verstärke die sich wie in einer selbst
filling profis deswegen glaube ich
diesen umfragen nicht ganz und wenn ich
ehrlich bin ich hoffe auch das ist so
nicht kommen
ja nicht heute den fragen schon wir
bitten die stimmung ab aber was was
richtig ist diese duell situationen die
wir in sachsen anhalt haben die haben
wir jetzt auch es geht jetzt um die
frage wer liegt vorne holz oder laschet
cdu oder spd und wenn so eine situation
entsteht dass die beiden großen
mobilisierenden dann hat die union die
erheblich größer und mobilisierungs
reserven deswegen es kommt auch dieses
wochenende an da gibt es ein parteitag
von der csu und es gibt einen trick ich
bin also ich lehne dies ab ich bin ja
wir sollten jetzt ein quartett oder ein
duell machen ja aber dieses wochenende
werden wir sehen ob meine wände
stattfindet oder nicht und laschet fährt
zum parteitag der csu das wird spannend
sowieso aber nun muss einmal über diese
sachsen-anhalt parallele sprechen ich
glaube die funktioniert hier einfach
nicht als sachsen anhalt gab es eine
polarisierung zwischen cdu und fdp und
die afg ist tatsächlich ein
schreckgespenst aber das schreckgespenst
dieses wahlkampfs wenn man zumindest ein
persönlichkeits werden glauben darf ist
nicht olaf scholz sondern dass es
er braucht man uns einst
verschiedentlich bekannt meint
gespenstes rot rot grün auch wir aber
das endet und man gerade nichts an den
umfragen und ich sehe es einfach nicht
dass die leute massenhaft zu armin
laschet überwechseln das mag bei der afg
so gewesen sein hier ist es nicht so und
wenn wir jetzt über das wochenende der
entscheidung sprechen dass wenn du
wochenende sozusagen
armin laschet fährt jetzt nach nürnberg
zur csu aber was erwartet ihn denn da da
erwartet mir keine große siegesfeier
nach der als großer siegreicher cdu
kandidat raus kommt und sagt hier wohl
jetzt führt anke habe ich gesagt ich
lass mal über die von diesem parteitag
im blick wir haben heute eigentlich bin
ich ganz sicher was kommen wird weil es
zu verrückt ist lasche tritt am
samstagabend als letzter redner des
parteitags auf so was verrücktes habe
ich nie gehört das sind alle schon weg
also wenn er pech hat spricht er vor
einer halbleeren halle daher wie kann
man auch so eine ehre sie haben also ist
schon schon kampagnenfähig und es ist
natürlich ein großes ja das sowieso aber
ich würde das nicht unterschätzen ist
ein medienereignis und natürlich stimmt
das denn wenn laschet in der
persönlichkeitswahl der würde jetzt
nicht mehr mobilisieren aber die
deutschen wählen keine person wir wählen
kann wurden das ganze wir wählen
parteien haben das stimmt das was gesagt
am ende ist die cdu eben das gewohnte
möbelstück im haus das man nicht so
leicht heraus haben wir die letzten 16
jahre nicht angela merkel gewählt und
nicht die cdu
ja aber trotzdem ist die ist das milieu
aus dem das kommt ein gefestigtes
bürgerliches milieu okay wir wissen
jetzt jedenfalls dass ihre welt hat
haben wir
19 bundestagswahl haben wir nicht angela
merkel gewählt zu stimmen
an diesem tisch kommt alles aus philipp
[Musik]